hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Katie -
blonde I'm super excited people have
been asking me to watch this video for
quite some time I have not seen the
first two so I always avoided it coming
to find out
Katie's seen the first two and she's
excited for the third one if man 3 and
this one starts Donny N and none other
than Mike Tyson huh how's your
excitement I'm excited still with Mike
Tyson I'm excited and I'm curious and
confused I mean this is about a real
person's life so like you would think
there's so much that happened in the
first two movies it's like what could
possibly be left in this guy's life -
what's the basic story of it so um if
man was Bruce Lee's master trainer cool
so this is a story of his life and all
of the things that he went through so
it's super badass you've got a
preserving Sheen no there it's it's the
best some of the best martial arts hands
down I didn't knows about that like I
love Bruce Lee dude I'm telling you it's
awesome
[ __ ] some [ __ ]
ouch
ah there's actually pretty cool so good
oh my god so good my Chuck Mike Tyson in
a movie has always seemed like a joke
but they did that in a way where I'm
like that's badass man well this guy
needs the Grand Master it needs like
that kind of a challenge yeah you know
he is so in control and so good in the
first movies you just see him just
completely take control of situations
that are seen like Wars like wars are
blossoming in his territory neighborhood
and he handles it so he needs someone
this big yeah someone this menacing
that's cool to see a martial artist take
on a boxer and he's like a legendary
boxer yeah so that's gonna be a cool
[ __ ] fight like with the court and he
looks committed like he had because I'm
like I think I'm Mike Tyson a movie I
think I'm like The Hangover films you
know so to see him in something so
serious mm-hmm
and that he was down for a forum flick
like that like that's cool well one of
the through lines of all these movies is
like this particular martial arts style
in approving itself amongst all of these
other styles so so the fact that they're
putting him up against a fighter like
Mike Tyson that makes sense because
they're relating this style to them and
the pride that comes with this style too
like this big you know American like
fist meet impact yeah there's still a
way to overcome that and some of my
favorite choreography in general when I
watch fight sequences as I grew up on
martial arts movies I stopped following
it as much actually around the time when
Donnie and started coming into the scene
he like started making appearances in
America I'm like Shanghai Knights is the
bad guy so he made some appearances but
around that time as I stopped following
him so much it was like Jackie Chan you
and bo-sama hung those days I thoroughly
recommend that everybody starts with me
getting watch the first two movies first
because they are both standalone
incredible movies and then it's going to
be another standalone
incredible movie I'm down I love I've
seen more Donnie and fights that I've
seen Donnie n movies and I love his
fight choreography some of my favorite
fight choreographies when you have two
very different styles going against each
other you know like it's cool when it's
like both of the same style but but it's
one thing when both styles are being
very much honored I think this style has
a lot to do with the flow of the water
if I remember correctly that's a
through-line its defensive right so it's
kung fu okay it's this type of kung fu
and it's defensive so one of the through
lines you know is that you don't have to
be the aggressor you can be the
protector but if [ __ ] goes down you can
handle yourself better because water is
even the most powerful element yeah okay
yeah King on right I think I'm right on
Spanish music super excited for this so
excited it man 3 I'm excited it looks
good it looks really good I'm gonna I'm
definitely gonna watch the first two I
think they're on Netflix in case you
guys don't know I used to do martial
arts frequently really I actually have a
fight scene in one of our sketches
called the raid 3 if you want to see
Ryan Wright throw a few kicks and
punches check that sketch out i'm ryan
right you saw the rain movies are also
awesome yeah yeah you see my sketch
right yeah I think I have already do
some kicks instead yeah yeah good you
throw down I throw down Rose rosette
let's go woman up [ __ ] I'm a chili I
really channel my inner crazy Eminem
just the songs about like abusing women
just really just a lot of that and then
I transferred into a sketch oh yeah when
a lady's kicking her butt in martial
arts you like have to find it inner
power yeah put your toes not quit to not
give up anyway guys if you're new to the
channel please do me this favor and
subscribe cuz right now it's about
reputation and I if I get a certain
number of followers
I can finally look cool in some circles
she needs it
yeah I needed it was seeing boost when I
go to parties and I'm like oh
I have 294,000 they're like wetter but
once in my 300,000 yeah and I'll be like
[ __ ] back off I got a hole already
and then she's gonna break over me for
saying that she has respect how many
slaps in the face you get in like an
evening well she takes it out on meager
insects cutie my god just click that
Catherine du Bois face make its around
Twitter YouTube me you him is a web
series launched on YouTube and she
guest-starred in it it's a good good
shot yeah I slapped some people in it so
we for that you know we're talking about
violence there's some good slaps
although we do not condone violence
unless it is revenge or humorous to
everyone involved yes and if you're just
into it like you and your girl might be
fornicating get a little violent the
better yeah it's like the deep sultry
voice came out Frank Ramos fragrance
mist his shout out but he left the
commenting sup bro where's my glorious
shut up and asking for one but you don't
hook it up makes me feel like a reject
slap on the knee that one Frank Ramos up
we did give you a shout out don't know
what video was in now normally I won't
riche out out someone they just happen
to miss theirs but he had a cool little
photo here um Jerry you have to come
here to see this photo look at that
that's you oh hey wassup guys wow I'm a
Rasta guy yeah look I got a real rejects
are are tattoo I feel like I could
actually pull that off it's cool you
look like like like they mixed you with
like Seth Rogen but also fat bastard's
hair